Now, we know you're a pretty good liar,
but what if you're caught by the enemy
and faced with a lie-detector test?
Michele Rigby Assad: OK, if
you are being polygraphed,
it's already too late.
Hi, I'm Michele Rigby Assad,
a former intelligence
officer with the CIA.
I spent the majority of my career
in the Middle East doing counterterrorism
and counterintelligence work.
And today we're going to review television
and movie clips to see,
are they real or not?
Sydney: Do you see anything?
Dixon: Get closer, I can't tell
if he's got the card on him.
Sydney: Anything?
Dixon: Yeah, the key card's
in his breast pocket.
Michele: The idea of having an earpiece
where you have immediate support
and targeting assistance
as you're carrying out your operation,
no, that does not happen.
I have never used multiple
wigs during an operation
or different sets of clothes.
I have changed my appearance.
I have put my hair up into
a ponytail or put a hat on
or changed a shirt or taken a shirt off.
It's very rare in your career
to require a big change of appearance
like you would see here in this clip.
Dixon: Hold that for 30 seconds.
The duplicate key card's printing.
Michele: The high-tech
nature of that piece,
being able to read the key card
and be able to then create
a new one based off of that,
I've never heard of that before.
Man: Wonderful. Yes, yes, well, of course,
getting funding is very difficult,
particularly in today's...
Michele: It's the oddest thing.
You can be on the edge of the earth
in a place that's not very well known,
and you could actually recognize
a CIA classmate or colleague,
but you do not cross paths.
You do not acknowledge each other,
because you could both be in
the middle of an operation.
And we try really hard to
de-conflict operations,
so you don't want to greet
them with the wrong name.
So you just kind of, like,
wink at each other and keep walking.
So, I would rate this clip as a one.
Not realistic at all.
Kittridge: I know how
much Jim, in particular,
meant to you, Ethan.
Ethan: Yeah.
Michele: It isn't unusual to have
an operational meeting in a restaurant.
They are seated right next
to the glass front of the building.
You would never sit there,
because presumably anybody walking by
on the street has a clear view
of this operational meeting taking place.
With high-end restaurants,
you're going to get
waiters and waitstaff there
incredibly attentive to
your needs as a diner,
and you don't want that.
You want to scope out the restaurant
and get a seat towards maybe the back
or the side of a restaurant.
You don't want it too noisy.
You don't want it too quiet.
And you also want to know
where the back entrance is.
So you want to be able to come and go
from separate entrances and exits
after meeting with a clandestine source.
So, this whole scenario
would have never actually
taken place in real life.
Ethan: Why was there another team?
Kittridge: What?
Ethan: Of IMF agents
at the embassy tonight.
Michele: Absolutely not.
That would never, ever happen,
and the reason is,
you have to have a full understanding
of everyone involved in the operation.
Everything you've done
is fully planned out
and de-conflicted with people in the area.
So if you were to notice the other team,
you would have called out the
operation from the beginning.
Kittridge: I can understand
you're very upset.
Ethan: Kittridge, you've
never seen me very upset.
Michele: That part is accurate.
The sense of no matter what happens,
you have to keep your head on straight.
You have to focus and
think, OK, what next?
[explosion]
They certainly make intel officers
look incredibly cool,
and who doesn't want explosive gum?
Love that.
I would give it
a two out of 10 for realism,
which doesn't mean I don't
absolutely love this movie.
I do, but not realistic at all.
Patrick: I was given the
specific instructions by Elaine
to tailor these gadgets to you.
Michele: Nothing on that table,
we wouldn't be using
anything of that nature.
The things that we are assigned
when we go to a war zone
are things like your Glock or your helmet
or your Kevlar vest.
When you are having an operation
that requires a piece of technology,
then you will go through
a very long process
of figuring out what the best
tech is for that scenario.
It's not issued to you
until you request it,
until you require that.
Patrick: This antifungal spray can freeze
and disable any security system.
Michele: What I love about
the silly items that he gives her,
are things she can stash in
her purse and her suitcase
and no one's ever really
going to think twice about.
The idea is to not stand out.
She's successful in this movie
because she's the unexpected spy.
You don't want people to take note of you.
We talk about lulling people to sleep.
Backstopping, like
you're creating a persona
and the persona's that you're just
a normal, everyday person,
and you even need things like this.
I give it a three.
But of course for fun I give it a 10.
Bourne: I can tell you
the license-plate numbers
of all six cars outside.
I can tell you that our
waitress is left-handed
and the guy sitting up at
the counter weighs 215 pounds
and knows how to handle himself.
Michele: Now, his powers of
recall are quite incredible
and unrealistic.
Essentially, you're trained
to remember people's profiles
when they stand out,
when they do something
that's unusual or different.
You're conducting a
surveillance detection route.
So you're making sure
nobody's going to follow you
to your clandestine meeting.
You want to make sure that you don't
see the same cars twice,
and so one technique that they teach us
is to speak out loud
a description of the various
vehicles that you're seeing.
So, it's called commentary driving.
This whole scenario
would have never actually
taken place in real life.
We learn how to use our car as a weapon
in case we're ambushed.
We learn how to drive a car.
Really drive it to its limits.
How to avoid impacting
casuals in the field.
I mean, it's the best.
It's, like, the coolest
part of our training,
but you hope you will never use any of it.
And so I was driving in my car alone,
and I was in the process of
possibly getting carjacked.
I had to use my vehicle to hit someone
a couple of times to get them to move
so I could drive out of harm's way,
and I didn't think too
much what I was doing about
as I was in the middle of this scenario,
but my training kicked in, thank God,
and I was able to get away,
and thankfully I also
didn't hurt that person.
I would give it a two
out of 10 for realism.
The idea that we shoot people
or we have black belts in martial arts
and we take people down with a kick,
the psychology of espionage
is very on the down low
and not in-your-face
action-packed sequences.
We did get some physical training,
and most of it was, you know,
what you do if things go really bad.
We get qualified on a Glock,
and we feel quite comfortable with a Glock
after that training.
So I would rate this clip as a one.
Jack: The game. When we were in Paris,
we uncovered correspondence
between Suleiman
and his brother, Ali.
Michele: So, the way the scene is set up,
with a room full of intelligence officers
from very, very senior
level all the way down
to junior-type officers, is quite unusual.
It might remind you
of something you have seen in the press,
and that is President Obama
sitting with his closest security
and intelligence advisors
as the operation against
Osama bin Laden unraveled.
They were right there along the way,
they heard the communications,
and you see them sitting
in the room together.
So, most of the time that doesn't happen.
That would have to be an incredibly
high-level-type operation,
but you would always
have people in the room
who are subject-matter experts.
You could speak up as a junior officer,
because you may be the
only one in the room
who actually has the substance
or the knowledge about your target.
Jack: They were using
a video-game system's
online-messaging app to communicate.
Michele: So, terrorists
and other criminals
have actually used the
chat function in games
to communicate with each other.
They have used it as a form
of covert communications.
We have the calculation
of risk versus gain.
So, would we try to insert
ourselves in a relationship
between two really close brothers?
You would walk into that
probably understanding
that you would not be able to have
the proper verbal paroles
to make the connection.
Jack: Who's got this?
Agent: Let's go, guys!
Get on it, get on it.
Michele: Most of our operations are not as
quickly unfolding or as rapid as this one.
The CIA is very much a bureaucracy,
like every US government agency,
and it takes us a long time
to plan, implement, execute operations.
There are very, very few
instances in your career
where something like that would happen,
where you're kind of jumping through hoops
and looking up information quickly.
I mean, we do do that, but it's not,
it's not as prevalent as this
clip would make you think.
Agent: He's still online, Jack.
Michele: I love the authenticity
of showing how a terrorist operates,
especially using the gaming chat.
Although, you know,
Hollywood amps it up a bit,
but because of all that,
I'd give it about a seven.
This clip makes me sweat,
because it is so realistic
in terms of what we deal with
when we're crossing borders
or getting ready to board a flight
or enter or exit a country.
It can be incredibly dicey.
Like, I feel all sweaty,
and my heart is racing even
thinking about it right now.
You have to be so confident
in keeping your cover and
maintaining your legend.
Even if your insides feel like
they're literally exploding,
you cannot show that on your face.
You have to remember who
you are, what your name is,
what you're doing, what your
purpose was in the country,
when you entered, when you exited.
In terms of your cover story,
you want to keep it as close
to the truth as possible
because you have to memorize it
and you have to recall it easily
and you have to recall it under stress.
This movie is based on
a real-life situation,
which is right after the
1979 Iranian Revolution.
Some Americans were able
to escape the embassy
and with the help of
the Canadian government
come up with this
operation to get them out.
So not only is it realistic,
but it really did happen.
They did actually have university students
putting those photos together
to try to figure out the identities
of all of the US embassy staff.
Guard: What was the purpose of your visit?
Bob: We are looking for
locations for a film.
Michele: Airport
authorities don't even have
to have a good reason to detain you
or to stop you from boarding a flight.
If they don't like the way you look
or they don't trust you
or you say something wrong,
that could change the
course of your entire life.
Technology has changed
a great deal since 1979,
when this happened, and it's
making it more difficult
for intelligence officers and others
to cross borders covertly,
because now we've got
all kinds of thumbprints
and eye scanners and
all kinds of equipment
that's used to establish your identity.
This one I give a nine,
because it's so close to accurate.
Lynne: I really don't
want to do this anymore,
and I mean it, Carrie.
I feel like I can't even breathe now.
Carrie: All you have to do now
is keep your eyes and ears open
for the remainder of your
contract with the prince.
Michele: So, I love this clip,
because it really shows
the bread and butter
of what it is to be an
intelligence officer.
The way that she handles
her source is not ideal.
She basically said, "You have to do this."
Oh, my goodness!
You would never say that to a real source.
They are there because
they want to be there.
they understand the risk
and they're willing to take the risk.
Now, what you have to do
is, if they're nervous,
if they're concerned about moving forward
or they feel like their life is in danger,
you have to talk them through that.
You have to train them.
And so the idea of telling her, like,
"You have to do this,"
is the worst way to treat a source.
Every time you have a source meeting,
if there's a lot on the
line with the source,
it's almost like you have to
re-recruit them every time.
Carrie: You are the only agency asset
to have had eyes on Nazir in seven years.
Lynne: Asset?
Michele: We do in fact
call our sources assets,
but we would never do that to their face,
because it's a very inhuman
way to refer to them,
and they are human beings.
Lynne: I am just some
girl from Sandusky, Ohio,
you talked into helping out her country.
Carrie: And I won't let
anything happen to you.
Michele: We are not God that
we can protect our sources.
There are certain things
in certain situations
that we can do to help our sources out,
but at the end of the day,
they're the ones on the front lines.
They're the ones in difficult situations,
and they're the ones who
have to make a decision.
So you have to help them
think through scenarios,
ways to ensure that they
keep themselves safe
and don't take any unnecessary risks.
Your sources may not intuitively
know what's too risky,
what they can get away with,
and if, at the end of the day,
they don't feel comfortable,
they can walk away at any time.
But the part of this
that is inaccurate to me
is the fact that a Western woman
who is the girlfriend of a sheikh
would be anywhere remotely
close to a wanted terrorist.
That would not happen.
She is unvetted, untested.
Fundamentally, she's a Western woman.
So that whole scenario
is extremely unlikely.
I would give this clip an eight,
only because it is the closest thing
to a real-life covert
meeting with a source
that I have ever seen in
the movies or on television.
JJ: Now, we know you're
a pretty good liar,
but what if you're caught by the enemy
and faced with a lie-detector test?
Michele: OK, if you are being polygraphed,
it's already too late.
If you are arrested or detained
by a foreign government
and you're being polygraphed,
done. You're finished.
You don't even want to get to that point.
JJ: The key is to focus on your breathing.
The slightest increase
in your blood pressure
is an indicator that you're
not telling the truth.
Michele: So, no, we are not trained
how to defeat the polygraph,
because, you know, once that happens,
you're already probably imprisoned.
So that's not accurate at all.
The agency uses the polygraph
as part of your security and
background investigation.
So basically if you train
someone to defeat it,
you're training your employees to defeat
one of the methods you
use to keep them honest.
So they would never want
to do something like that.
Nathan: I can probably make arrangements
for you to end your tour
of duty in San Diego,
in which case I'll presume you'll forget
we ever had this conversation.
Michele: Getting personally
recruited in that manner,
so, while I know a couple of people
that that happened to,
the vast majority of us
actually apply to the CIA
online or through someone that we know.
Nathan: The next day, we
started his tradecraft.
Michele: Wow.
No, it could take an entire
year for the CIA to vet you,
and you have to go through
so many processes of polygraphs
and very long interviews and psych exams,
and so you have to go
through a battery of tests
before you get to the part
where you're actually
going through training.
Now, in terms of your tradecraft training,
that takes about a year,
and it's very, very intense,
and it's not one-on-one like you see here.
You have classroom time,
and then you have role
playing in the field,
and you do go out in public
and you practice your skills.
So that part is accurate.
Nathan: Always carry
cigarettes and a lighter, too.
Great icebreaker.
Michele: Now, the whole
"cigarettes and a lighter,"
they can be very useful,
especially in parts of the world
where smoking is a big thing.
So, I spent a lot of
time in the Middle East,
and a lot of people smoked.
They were quite useful for
when you were serving in
really dangerous places,
where there are a lot of military
or criminal checkpoints.
A pack of cigarettes
or a box of cigarettes
could potentially save your life.
It's very valuable in
certain parts of the world,
so you would keep that in
your glove-compartment box.
Nathan: The suit in the kitchen.
Threat?
Tom: Wait, how'd you see that?
Michele: Every time we can use a mirror
or a glass door or a glass
window to see a reflection,
oh, that's the best.
Intelligence officers love reflections.
Nathan: Solicit information from someone.
Tom: Gladly.
Michele: Elicitation is one
of the most important skills
that you have as an intelligence officer.
So, you would need to be able
to talk people into doing things for you.
You need to have the
emotional intelligence
that allows you to make a connection
to ultimately recruit and handle sources,
or just to kind of get through your day,
maintain your cover and your, you know,
your lifestyle abroad, whatever that is.
But those are really critical skills.
I rate this a seven.
It's...
there's some inauthentic pieces,
but I like it as a whole.
Roger: Mr. Al-Masri?
Mr. Omar Sadiki.
Sadiki: As-salamu alaikum.
Al-Masri: Wa alaikum assalaam.
[camera clicking]
Michele: So, what I find
inauthentic about this scene
is that you have your target
and then an operator
almost crossing paths.
That would never happen in real life.
So, of course, what's happening here
is the target is being set up
to be photographed with
another individual.
You would have coordinated,
in an operation like
this, way ahead of time,
and not in the actual office
where it's going to occur.
This is what you call
the operational bubble,
and you have to get outside
that operational bubble
to do something like photograph these two.
And you saw this huge
lens that he's using.
That's going to grab a lot of attention.
So it's highly likely
someone would have seen him
in the car with this ginormous lens.
If there'd been another car
on the other side of him, possibly,
but he wouldn't even need a lens that big,
because he's really not that far away.
We would have definitely
created a scenario
where you get your target
into a specific location,
but you want to protect
your technical asset who's
taking the photograph.
So you want them to be outside
the operational bubble.
So that's the part that's
not authentic here.
I'd probably give it around a six,
so slightly authentic,
but there are a lot of problems here,
as we've pointed out.
Who doesn't love Melissa
McCarthy in "Spy"?
I laugh out loud at this movie.
She is so brilliant.